[Music]
on this Saturday night a brutal beating
and a national Reckoning
the calls for calm is simmering protests
hit a boiling point we can't let him why
can't we let up because we're still
being murdered as damning footage of
Tyree Nichols final moments Sparks
outrage and questions Plus
just one sound of my kid whining and I
turn around and he's on the ground the
little boy in crisis who landed in
handcuffs how his mother says this
could have all been avoided and
anniversary of an occupation
protesters returned to Parliament Hill
one year after the Convoy that rolled in
to the country's capital also I'm very
honored
to be able to live to see this day the
settlement for survivors of the
residential school system the proposal
for the billions awarded in an
unprecedented class-action agreement
global national with Paul Nasser
reporting tonight Sarah McDonald
good evening thanks for joining us hours
before footage was released showing five
police officers dealing what would
ultimately be fatal blows to Tyree
Nichols in Memphis his family called for
calm and peaceful protests in their home
state of Tennessee and Beyond and
tonight that's largely what they've
received as people across the country
demand Justice for the 29 year old who
was recorded by body cameras saying he
was just trying to get home during a
fateful traffic stop Jennifer Johnson
begins our coverage with the continuing
follow tonight including two suspensions
of more officers and a warning what
you're about to see is disturbing oh
from coast to coast thousands of angry
Americans took to the streets following
the release of the shocking video
showing Memphis police officers tasing
punching and stomping 29 year old Tyree
Nichols during a traffic stop Nichols
died in a hospital three days later all
five former officers were fired and have
been charged with second-degree murder
and other criminal offenses if it wasn't
for the George Floyd Uprising this
Justice here wouldn't be so slick but we
can't let them why can't we let up
because we're still being murdered
the protests were mostly peaceful but
tempers flared in New York City and Los
Angeles it
is because no mother shouldn't have to
witness what that what we saw
two
mom at one point on the police cam video
Nichols has heard calling out for his
mother her home was about 70 meters from
where the altercation occurred this just
shouldn't have happened
and
we want Justice for my son as millions
of Americans struggle to watch the
horrific video U.S President Joe Biden
expressed his condolences to Nichol's
mother promising a thorough federal
civil rights investigation it has a lot
to say and do with the image of America
all five former officers are now out on
bail the local sheriff's department has
also suspended two deputies who came
onto the scene after the beating and
there are now questions as to why
Nichols reportedly laid on the ground
for at least 20 minutes before
paramedics called to the scene treated
him
attorneys for at least two of the
officers say they will plead not guilty
asking the public to withhold judgment
you're going to feel things you're going
to
experience emotions
but know that there's always more to the
story
Millions now want answers as to why this
traffic stop turns so violent and ended
up costing Nichols his life the
investigations have just begun
as protesters vow to keep demonstrating
until real police reforms are adopted
across America
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
and Canadian police Chiefs are also
denouncing Tyree Nichols death demanding
the officers involved be held
accountable Toronto's police chief
saying in a statement on behalf of the
Toronto Police Service I condemn the
violent actions of the officers involved
Ottawa Police Service also commenting We
join in the calls for justice and we
support the steps being taken to fully
investigate the incident and hold the
individuals accountable and the Alberta
police Chiefs Association adding we
categorically condemn the actions that
resulted in this senseless loss of life
here in Canada another video involving
police and a handcuffed indigenous child
with autism in British Columbia is
sparking outrage and many questions
you're too much
you're a little too much this is too
much
that is the voice of the boy's mother
Maya who says she started recording this
footage the second time her son was
placed in handcuffs the footage which
has since been posted and circulated
widely on social media was taken inside
BC Children's hospital on Thursday
evening the officers had escorted Maya
and her son there after a previous
incident on Transit autism rights
Advocates and the boy's mother say the
situation could have been de-escalated
well before it got to this point
to de-escalate that situation they could
have used their words I didn't want to
be that person to post a video about the
police because they've helped me but
just one sound of my kid whining and I
turned around and he's on the ground and
I I try to get on top of him and take
the hands off my kid but they were I I
had to video record I'm sorry I had to
video record I
because you can't do that behind closed
doors
today marks a not so pleasant
anniversary for the nation's capital
it's been one year since the Convoy
protest that rolled into Ottawa and shut
down the city's core for almost a month
today along with demonstrations in
several other Canadian cities to Mark
the occasion hundreds of anti-government
protesters also returned to the Capitol
though as turia Israeli reports there
were some notable differences
365 days later
[Applause]
the freedom Convoy returned to Ottawa
but this time demonstrators were forced
to walk to Parliament Hill Wellington
Street remains closed to traffic and
that led to a smaller more subdued
protest I live here in Ottawa and I
actually miss the sound of the horns
those blaring horns
have been replaced by music
protesters gathered for what they dubbed
a dance party under a heavy police
presence this is anniversary a
celebration of something we've we've
achieved Public Health restrictions may
be gone but the anger against prime
minister Justin Trudeau is not I'd like
to see a change of government but that's
not going to happen today or tomorrow
and I understand that I just like to see
less division within our country we are
as po we laugh at the United States
we're no different right now
those divisions were on display hey hey
come here a counter protester clashed
with a member of the freedom Convoy a
big bunch of whiny babies
through a mega tantrum last year in our
city the crowd gathered on Parliament
Hill at the same time the liberal caucus
was meeting behind us in West block some
of the protesters here say they would
still like prime minister Justin Trudeau
to meet with them and hear their
concerns Trudeau is acknowledging the
frustration I think responsible
leadership is acknowledging the concerns
and anger that people are feeling and
look to solve for look to provide
Solutions look to reassure people not to
amplify that anger the conservatives are
also holding their caucus Retreat I
think we need to actually look into all
aspects of the pandemic and how it was
handled things are being looked at
including the federal government's use
of the emergencies act the findings are
due next month while some of the main
protest leaders are facing charges
political experts predict the current
climate of polarization is here to stay
the fire was already going and the
pandemic was an accelerant along those
lines so uh so the disc course I think
has been changing for quite a while and
that discourse may be a preview of what
to expect during the next session of
parliament teria Israeli Global News
Ottawa
at least three people are dead and
California's latest mass shooting the
fourth this month alone it happened
early this morning in Los Angeles inside
a car outside a short-term rental
property another four people were
injured in the incident investigators
are now trying to determine what led up
to those shots being fired last year the
United States recorded more than 600
mass shootings
another attack in Jerusalem has
heightened fears of escalating violence
between Israelis and Palestinians
officials saying a 13-year-old
Palestinian boy wounded two Israelis a
father and son today this latest
incident coming one day after another
person killed seven near a synagogue
scene after
after skirts of this city the day before
on Thursday Israeli forces killed 10
Palestinians in a raid on the West Bank
City of Janine fueling this latest
escalation
and joining us now with the latest from
Jerusalem is Reuters correspondent Emily
Rose Emily you're close to where the
attacks have been happening take us
there what is the feeling on the ground
so the feeling today Sarah it's like a
Tinder Box that could go up in Flames at
every moment but we have to remember
that actually the violence and though it
has been a violent 48 hours it's really
the culmination of violence that began
earlier part of last year when Israel
stepped up the number of raids it was
conducting in the West Bank in response
to a state of Palestinian Street attacks
and I have to see it Reuters Jerusalem
we've been reporting since then almost
weekly on clashes between the Israeli
military and Palestinians on the ground
these really militaries saying that
those Palestinians are militants that
they aim at killing or hurting Israeli
civilians or soldiers and the
Palestinians the ones who take up arms
say that they're engaging in armed
struggle against Israel's occupation of
Palestinian cities and towns so all of
the past 40 hours have really just been
a fever pitch of that violence that has
been culminating for over a year now and
speaking of the military you've been
speaking to your resources in the
Israeli military what can we expect in
the coming hours and days given the
escalation in violence
yes I just spoke to a senior member of
the Israeli military who informed me
that they've dispatched an additional
three battalions to the West Bank he
wouldn't give me the percentage of what
that means in terms of boots on the
ground but he did say that comprises a
sizeable increase in the number of
soldiers that are being sent out there
now that could have a double effect
right it could create more friction with
Palestinians on the ground but he said
that the Israeli military was doing so
and they would continue to send more
soldiers if they saw fit and if you look
at the streets on the ground here in
Jerusalem you can see heightened police
presence security Personnel everywhere
they're really looking like they're
anticipating more violence more clashes
specifically around East Jerusalem and
the old city so it's not a stretch to
say that Israeli security personnel and
Israeli forces are on high alert okay
and adding to all of this Israel now has
a new far-ride government how should
this violence be looked at within the
context of this new leadership
so it's important to remember that that
new government was already under the
international lens a few weeks back it
said that it was going to introduce new
judicial reforms that would strip the
Israeli Supreme Court of a lot of its
power and pass it over to members of the
governing Coalition now that sparked
Iyer among members of the International
Community who said that would make
Israel less Democratic but it also made
Israelis quite angry and for the fourth
week in a row tens of thousands of
Israelis have taken to the street to
protest those judicial reforms so that
was already going to be an element of
the discussion when members of the
International Community do touch down
this week specifically members of the
American government but this new
security situation adds another element
to those discussions okay Emily Rose in
Jerusalem thank you Emily for your
insights on such a delicate and dynamic
situation this evening
thank you
it is a class action settlement unlike
anything this country has seen before
coming up the proposed plan for billions
of dollars awarded to survivors of the
residential school system that's after
the break stay with us
more tonight on a 2.8 billion dollar
residential school class action
settlement in a lawsuit brought by
members of a BC first nation in 2012.
Canada has agreed to pay the money into
a trust fund with more details of the
agreement said to be released next month
in the meantime more announcements this
week about potential Graves being
detected on the grounds of those former
residential schools near Williams Lake
BC on Wednesday 66 new anomalies were
reported to be found on the grounds of
one adding to the 93 already announced
this time last year nithu garchin now
with reaction to the government's
proposed reparations for the destruction
of language and culture caused by those
institutions and how the funds may be
used
after Saddle Lake Cree Nation in Alberta
released its preliminary findings this
week including suspected causes of death
of some of an estimated 400 children who
didn't survive the lead investigator
reacted to the 2.8 billion dollar
residential school class action
settlement the monies will never be able
to according to our elders repay the
uh cultural language and uh if I may say
a spiritual losses I'm very honored
to be able to live to see This Day Shane
goffertson has been involved in this
case as a representative plaintiff for
15 years he says the agreement marks
Canada's first class action settlement
for Collective damages based on shared
rights to indigenous language and
culture and 10 days before a trial was
to start Canada offered to settle
so today we are representing 325
indigenous Nations across Canada and
have developed a settlement plan to
allow for the Nations to work towards
the four pillars those four pillars of
the 2.8 billion dollar agreement are
revitalization of language culture
Wellness for people and Heritage
commemoration possibly a full immersion
school you know teaching the language
for our kids for upper Nicola band Chief
and residential school survivor Harvey
McLeod the money will bolster and speed
up existing language and culture
programs in his community he says the
focus will be on children the ceremony
is like
horse clinic for six to eight euros how
to take care of a horse
fishing hunting
um Gathering medicines and just getting
out under the land and finding out what
this land is all about he says it shows
ottawa's commitment to making amends but
indigenous legal scholar Rachel Snow who
was not involved in the case has a
different perspective I don't feel that
goes far enough at all because um
if you look at the level of dysfunction
and harm and hurt in our communities
um
it's this is this is Generations in the
making it's going to be Generations in
the the healing or fixing Crown
indigenous relations Minister Mark
Miller said the trust fund will operate
for 20 years and run independent of the
federal government if the court approves
the deal next month
Global News Vancouver
[Music]
just ahead torrential rain and fatal
flooding the deadly downpour in New
Zealand and the Frantic rush to evacuate
that's after the break stay with us
New Zealand's most populous city has
started cleaning up from deadly flash
flooding on the heels of its wettest day
on record
[Applause]
at least three people have been killed
in the flooding in Auckland with one
still missing the city logged nearly 250
millimeters of rain in just 24 hours on
Friday far surpassing its record from
1985 of 161 millimeters while heavy
rains eased today another downpour could
be coming with the impact expected to be
severe given how saturated the ground
already is
Canada's top Soldier is sounding the
alarm over the actual strength of our
country's defense capabilities in an
interview for the West block chief of
Defense staff General Wayne Ayer voices
candid concerns over the current state
of Canada's military one that's
grappling with dwindling Personnel
numbers and aging equipment in the face
of escalating Global threats here's what
he told our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson
you are facing some extraordinary
constraints both with personnel and it's
been no secret you've spoken publicly
about how constrained you are because
you are struggling with recruiting
people and you are struggling with
retention we know you're struggling with
equipment too whether it's that we only
have four tanks we can really send and
feel secure about our own Supply to
things like a ship the hmcs summer side
which took on water last week after a
sea valve failed a very old ship
concerns about Navy equipment concerns
about whether or not the Army is going
to get the equipment it needs replaced
concerns about airplanes and whether or
not the cf-18s keep flying what are the
limitations that you're facing right now
with equipment and Personnel meaning for
what you're capable of actually doing so
it comes down to Readiness and what I
mean by that is our ability to respond
at speed and at scale with the right
capabilities you know we can still
respond pretty fast but are we big
enough for what the uh what the
requirement is and so we we need to work
on all of those those factors you know I
am concerned because we see that
increased demand signal around the world
and here at home because our security
situation globally is deteriorating and
what that means is the country is going
to require more and more out of the
Canadian Armed Forces in the years to
come and so our job is to be ready
I think it's fair to say that we're in a
decade of Darkness it was used about the
90s but I keep hearing it from troops
and from retired generals is this a new
decade of Darkness
history will tell I think it's too early
to say if it's a history if it's a
decade of Darkness you know I've
certainly faced some challenges in in
this position
um and the Armed Forces writ large is
are facing some challenges
um but our job is to do everything we
can within our power to make it better
to be ready
and you can watch more of Mercedes
interview with General Wayne Air Sunday
on the west block right here on global
[Music]
up next the Homegrown Oscar nominees
headed to Hollywood meet the Alberta
based filmmakers ready to hit the red
carpet that's after the break
this year's Oscar nominations were
announced earlier this week and it's no
secret that getting a nod for Cinema's
biggest award show can be life-changing
Norma Reed now on a Calgary Duo
nominated for their animated short
inspired by an explosive moment in
Canadian history
I'm now the nominees for best animated
short film it's how one reacts when they
find out they're going to the Oscars the
flying sailor
oh
I mean we went nuts yes it was 6 30 in
the morning we went crazy two Calgary
filmmakers nominated for their stunning
animated short the flying sailor
it's their take on a little-known true
story of the Halifax explosion of 1917
where two boats collided a sailor caught
up in the world's largest accidental
blast
ing him two kilometers through the air
and he landed in a place called Fort
Needham Park wearing nothing but one
rubber boot and he was alive he
revisits memories and eventually kind of
goes into the white light before he's
sucked back down to the chaos again the
nomination is creating Buzz at Calgary's
Bow Valley College to be honest I was
like I kind of expected it the
instructor John John atianza worked on
the film he says attention from the
academy inspires future talent I could
just go to the closest city city Le
Calgary and I could learn all the
Hollywood techniques basically to be
able to work with some of these people
and be taught by them it's incredible
when we heard the story joining us from
the Sundance Film Festival the creators
are thankful for what will be their
third trip to the awards one of their
biggest hopes one day meeting the
sailors real life descendants we have no
idea who they are where they are we know
he went back to Liverpool and became a
Riverboat pilot the big question now
what are we gonna wear
Norma Reed
Global News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Sarah McDonald
tonight's your Canada is Galena British
Columbia thanks for watching nitu Garcia
will be here at the anchor desk tomorrow